Montana where the state's first
transgender lawmaker has been officially
barred from the house floor the move
follows days of protest after the
Republican majority banned state
representative her name is Zoe Zephyr
from speaking over a remark she made
about a bill to ban gender affirming
care Carter Evans has more from Helena
that's the state capitol
32 have voted no motion passes for the
second time in about three weeks a state
house with a republican majority has
voted to silence a democratic state
representative this time in Montana for
more than a week the state's first
transgender lawmaker was prevented from
speaking after a comment she made while
opposing a Republican bill Banning
gender affirming care for minors if you
vote Yes on this bill I hope the next
time there's an invocation when you bow
your heads in prayer you see the blood
on your hands
on Monday she raised a microphone to the
gallery in defiance as her supporters
chanted
[Applause]
on Wednesday she refused to apologize
the Republican majority unanimously
voted to ban Zephyr from the floor for
the rest of the legislative session
which ends in a few weeks if you could
do this over Would You Do Anything
differently
I am proud for standing up for my
community and I would never change
standing up for my community and my
constituents law is targeting gender
affirming care for minors have exploded
around the country 17 States now have
bans in place and 16 more including
Montana are currently considering a ban
the fact that this is happening is
just psychologically traumatizing when
you pass laws that we know are going to
result in more transgender people ending
their lives it's transgender genocide
now the bills
now the bill Zephyr is imposing and that
passed in the house would ban surgery
and hormone treatments for minors under
18. now Zephyr says she was elected by
about 11 000 people and she plans to
represent those constituents as long as
they'll have her Tony
all right Carter thank you very much